i want you to remember back on tuesday's
lesson we introduced this idea
of resisted motion and we had a look at
um
swimmers and cyclists that are resisted
by the medium that they're traveling
through if you had a look at the
exercise you would have noticed there
are some situations where
maybe it's not the medium but it's
friction for example or like putting on
the brakes
in in your car that can you know
behave essentially like a resistance
force and i should point out right now
by the way
um you'll go on to canvas um you know
shortly this morning
to have a look at the assigned questions
in the calendar as usual um but
something i didn't put an announcement
for because i assume
and correct me if i'm wrong in the chat
by the way i assume several of you are
kind of
inundated by announcements and emails
and all the rest
i didn't decide to put another one in
but if you look at our
you know outline page where you've got
the zoom link for this morning
you will have noticed that i put up a
series of videos
on what's it called it's one of the
questions in the
science exercise and it's a plane that
lands and then it starts breaking in a
couple of different ways and that's the
resistance force that it experiences
so i unpack that question there are some
sort of curveballs in there that are
quite important
which i didn't cover in tuesday's lesson
so please make sure you have a look at
that i think the example will be
instructive for you
now we kind of flagged on tuesday that
we're looking at horizontal resistant
motion because it's
in a way it's simpler you don't have to
think about gravity which
is is kind of an important force to take
into account
but now we're going to plow right into
that we're going to think about vertical
resisted motion and as you can imagine
just like with swimming and cycling the
examples i gave before
there are some situations where if you
don't take
uh say air resistance into account in a
vertical
um situation well you pull the parachute
and then you just drop like a rock so
thankfully parachutes um are one of the
situations where
errors is so significant well it will
save a life and let you land
um there are also some really memorable
examples of what happens when you take
away
air resistance um there's a video i'm
going to post the link in the chat later
not now because then you'd watch it
because it's super interesting but the
physicist brian cox did this amazing
experiment
uh in an enormous vacuum chamber that uh
i think nasa uses for some of its
testing
it's huge and they suck all the air out
of it and then they suspend a bowling
ball
and a feather from the ceiling of the
vacuum chamber and then they hit release
and because all the air has been taken
out
uh it doesn't behave like you would
normally expect a bowling ball and a
feather to behave
it behaves like this and
it almost looks like it's not real
actually when you see it it's like was
this computer generated but
sure enough they set the release and
this um this footage
is in real time and it's quite
astonishing even though
we know that this should be what happens
all the way back from galileo's famous
experiment
but it is still really weird and
counter-intuitive to actually see it
in person so we've mentioned the
vertical resistive motion is a little
bit trickier because you've got to think
about gravity
so let's talk about that now if you
haven't already made the heading do
make it vertical resisted motion and
then make a little subheading under that
and i want to think about the difference
between up and down in a vertical
resisted
motion setting okay now
when we think about um resistance and
let's just talk about air resistance for
now um because
or sort of the medium resistance this
would be the same you know traveling
through water and all that kind of thing
resistance is going to exert some kind
of force on you right
now remembering that force equals mass
times acceleration
i'm just going to write down mass here
because that's going to be included
and the whole idea here i even flagged
this right at the beginning of mechanics
is that the faster you go good morning
the faster you go
the more that medium will push back
against you right
um you know physically speaking you're
just ramming into more particles more
molecules of air or water or whatever it
is the faster you're going right
so we're going to be proportional to
some kind of um you know quantity of the
velocity right
so that proportion we often write as a k
where k is some kind of constant
you will frequently see that it's just
multiplied by the velocity so
occasionally they will say it's the
square of the velocity so
say in the parachute situation over here
that parachute so effectively slows you
down that um if you're going fast then
the
resistance against you will be in
proportion to the square of that because
there's so much area slowing you down
the most important thing here is
remember
it's resisting your velocity right so if
you're going to be moving
say in the positive direction then the
resistance force will be acting in the
negative direction and vice versa if you
were moving if your velocity is in the
negative direction
then your resistance is going to be in
the positive
direction so to capture that you know to
make sure that we get whatever is the
opposite
of the sine of the velocity we just slap
a minus sign
out the front and i hope this rings a
bell from simple harmonic motion
you might recall you don't need to write
this down because you've got it nestled
somewhere in your book
if you were thinking about the
differential equation for
um simple harmonic motion we would say
it's something like this right
obviously we could alter it if we had a
different center of motion it'd be x
minus
x naught or something like that but in
this case here it's like well if you're
displaced off to say
the left then this negative sign means
your force
uh your acceleration is going to be
acting towards the right and and vice
versa right
so that's what we're getting in this
situation
but and now this is the important part
and this is what we need to think about
in the
next few questions we're going to do
together gravity's
you've got to consider it differently
when you're going up versus when you're
going down
right so if for example i'm just going
to put a big curly brace here because
i'm going to think about two different
situations
if you are i'm starting from the ground
and then you you know say like a rocket
you know
it forces you it shoots you up right or
just like a ball that you project
through the air
okay the resistance in the medium
if you're traveling upward is going to
be acting downward no big deal this this
equation captures that even that's like
a v question like that right
but the gravity is also going to be
slowing you down so in such a situation
that force of gravity is acting against
you so in that situation it would be
minus g right uh or minus mg because i'm
thinking about the force and not just
the acceleration right
but if we were thinking about the
opposite end you know you reach the
you know the top of where you can go the
highest you can reach and then
you know what comes up uh what goes up
must go down come down
you know as long as you don't have extra
thrust taking you out of the atmosphere
in such a situation it is convenient to
think about that situation as
you know having the um downward
direction the direction you're traveling
thinking about that as positive um it
just makes all of our equations much
easier to deal with less minus signs and
all the rest we've done this
several times so under such a situation
when we think about this as the sort of
upward journey
what we would do is we would redefine
the situation
as downward being positive so this is
the direction you're now moving in which
means that
the force of gravity is now assisting
it's actually accelerating you
faster and so you would actually think
of gravity daisy when i write an m
you would think of gravity as increasing
the magnitude
um that's the direction the force is
going it's with your journey
if you are going downward so this just
difference here right means that and
this is not the only way to conceive
of the situation you can come up with a
whole bunch of different models that
will all
uh articulate and help you solve um a
problem to do with just emotion
this does tend to make our um this is
the simplest way to tackle such problems
and so you're gonna have a different
model
for um the upward part of the journey as
compared to the downward part
of the journey and you will see the
questions kind of unpacking for you
either they'll just focus on one half of
the journey
um or they will say okay go up then
pause
redefine everything um and sometimes
they even you know reset time and all
that kind of thing and then head
down so this is my summary for you
when we're thinking about the forces
that are acting on an
object in vertical resisted motion okay
um if you think about i
flip my colors around that was a bit
embarrassing so let's change that
to that and change that sorry pedantic
um
when you think about going upwards right
you've got gravity
and you've got air resistance or the
medium's resistance i keep saying air
it doesn't have to be air could be water
or something like that viscous fluid of
any kind
you've got both of them acting against
you and slowing you down so that's why
you can see these minus signs here
but when you're going downward gravity
like i said is assisting you or it's
it's trying to make you go faster right
so that's why you can see it represents
a positive
but the resistance of the medium is
still pushing against you as you would
hope
in this kind of parachute situation here
right so it's going to be slowing you
down
that's how we would articulate the
forces um if you were thinking about
just the acceleration
because we know that f equals m a um the
only difference is you're just not
worrying about mass
right we've seen this before but you
often see these equations
both turn up and it's like is mass there
or is it not right in a sense
it doesn't matter whether it is there or
not because the mass will just be a
constant
um we're not thinking about relativistic
situations where the faster you go the
more mass you have
it's just a constant so it can actually
be captured within say this this k
right but the simplest way to think
about it is if f
equals m a and this second row here is
just
a then i'm just dividing through by mass
okay